parent world is unforgivable so later on
if you want to speak up so i will talk
about 2.1 and it's not like a reality
really sure so what what does it mean
and is it really don't you what is those
promises and are going to use a tank how
can we use it and so on but obviously
it's more i want to raise more questions
than actually well first question four
units does anybody hear it uses role
evil yep this one is fine you do wow
that's good i know that another
developer so all right you go swimmin oh
no actually counted you yeah it's one
thirty boxes maybe that's it i can write
which is a calendar sweetie yeah well i
was actually thinking because i have BEC
many swimmers well it's basically a it's
being promoted in as well as a natural
extension of first more coffee sugar
your way and this is things you can
create web pages on passes and you can
use this tool great community and it's a
powered search engine for your own
community so you can tailor to produce
only like targeted search results that
your communities actually using its how
that you see that we come with us
because it's still rather than from you
sweetie shows and thoughts clouds or
what is important within your community
and it shows you what is hot within your
community and so it makes it easy best
conference dozen people discussing with
you and use it in power another one
yellow arrow this is a basically as a
social that one that helped everybody at
Chi su the way I asked her to be able
now it's a special allocation project
started regret New York and anyone can
mark the places of interest with it
young sticker and that's how a story
about that particular place right now
and place yellow arrows in a common
phrase of your only choice and they make
a digital photo often can post that
image with a personal description and on
the website and that leads to a man on
the website and when people come across
a yellow arrow somewhere in a public
space if you call from my mobile phone
and exit the informational websites
apprentices and moderate religion this
is an example of somebody hasta el area
so there's we're not on there you can
call it something person who threw that
sticker out there in left a message for
you when in car newspapers so basically
it's just an offline online community
being sober across platforms where
people try to do some social networking
and without actually knowing each other
photography for each other so what we
like to think now is the wreck is
wearing leather has has come from a
state of shock
and now we see where as not going to get
internet you do things on them so it's
one per place to do things to do at the
same time it's also seen as assigned
house we are now doing to think of that
it's a way to express ourselves in
various ways of you people to be about
favorite band don't fail to be
accompanied the so on now at least we
can put our people and extension trouble
arises so I'm talking about the web to
point out which is like a fool and
there's also of course assuming that
wasn't so now I was talking about that
little bit so basically want and so the
point to point out if you think about
giving so many times like Nazca is like
an old software Paragon basically a
flagship product the web browser so long
to text on application and the strategy
was to use their dominance and housing
market to establish my fav truth to a
high-powered server a server problem if
you think about Google become pro trust
that began inside as a native web
application there was never sold a
package but it was deliberately service
and where customers can pay directly or
indirectly using that service so the
central principle kind of success of two
giants such as humans such as netscape
we do that were born even went
wonderfully él era to have survived and
went on to the web 2.0 and
appears to be that I have embraced the
power of of the web and insofar as
collective intelligence per se so
examples are hyper linking and which is
that obviously the abomination off the
road but as used to add new content
emphasize found into the structure of
the rep itself but our use of
discovering it and making other content
to it and also Google's great through
with regard to or in search which
quickly made it into a very undisputed
search market leader was page references
which was a method of using the league
structure of the web honored them are
the just the characteristics of the
documents to provide the research
results another example be based product
is a collective creativity of all its
users so lightly let itself be big girls
organically and in response to use their
activities and companies roll their
fridges that has become enabled on the
compact food on a context in which you
to actively can't happen so they
provided a spaceman what's more Eva's
competitive advantage and overcomes
almost entirely from the critical mass
expires and consumers which makes any
new you may you entered operate summer
services less attractive so if you check
out our innovative companies online pick
up on this inside of trying to engage
people users computers audiences
whenever people to call them in into
this inside of both in turn actually
come on equal rather than social
networking
later then you can also Christmas then
I'll talk about Wikipedia who is using
that i'ma fix it out in people using
delicious liquor RF people about human
reference so you have like all these
different slides you do different things
it's about collaborative back filtering
for my photo sharing on flickr and so on
that's what what's being referred to as
we've got to point out how this came
about basically last year conference
which is actually ecology you know Tim
around and made a list for the core
competencies of what vet to photo should
be
so let's go with the corrugated a few
examples or comforter companies that we
think we see of social networking
companies or that offer his kind of
service overly if you think about it in
terms of data then it basically means
that it's all about the location that
identity you on the contrary colony
Republicans product identifiers
namespaces any kind that that kind of
thing as is the opportunity for
companies applicant almost the Intel
Inside playing with a single sewer
treatment they doctored everyone some
aggravation in terms of aggravated
asthma index system service so software
as a service and is one song about
software is no longer any product image
yourself you're trying to use your
supper are the basically perspective you
to think that directly as a service to
your potential clients the offering it
states where users but but be treated as
co-developers within that space and so
in the reflection for instance of all
the source development practices and so
the oats are thick and princesses
release earthy and release offer in fact
that hasn't looked into a green one
radical position which is called the
perpetual debt in which the product is
developed is open wooden features
slipstream into a muffin a believer that
even a daily basis and it's no accident
that those kind of services such as
Gmail Google Maps flickr editions of
young ones and they expect to update
well also another one is there a lot
about services amount of participation
most affected obviously when you park on
RC software as a service that means that
and if you also invite your little there
are other people to co-develop directly
from house effective at the same time to
supplement program should be very easy
and very simple so there's an exploring
these these principles that are the
strategic position in music associated
in the court I highlighted stuff ala
principal features of the rack to
Prudhoe age of obvious examples
demonstrate both through all these key
principles but maybe it's ours mr.
president for what's less Lewis by
summarizing I believe to be your key
aspects if you have to eat or no and
services perfect well so are not
packaged it software with Coast
effective similarly the second one is
control over unique too hard to recreate
our resources and that have richer as
more people use them the third would
would be trusting users really important
joselito as code numbers then all would
be horrible African governments you to
bit more leveraging the motel through
customer self-service and software
should be taken about the level of a
single revive so it's going to be across
platforms so not only am I
computer girls they want on your iPod
whatever else you're using and it should
be very lightweight for easy to use user
interfaces and development models and
especially business models as we heard a
similar physical shape Eugene's Sarah
looking at this one and all of that site
is are giving our soon weather affect
140 was it was a lot about to really
it's not exactly which is not that lucky
boy it's centralized the store at mass
media to social media from information
to collective intelligence for all
metrics to new realities and that was
social by default it's of social by
design and architectural design for
participation and so this is a short
summary of what I believe any key
aspects so the left it's connected to
all these different devices across
platforms it's really about reusable
services and data it's about data
consumption remix you from all these
different sources that are online in our
operation and I where I was wrong
different in the app at Forbes is
architecture participation which
encourages users and customer bution
operations is for simple programs and
people
it's all about operations across
platforms so if you develop some
software issue not only do one free
website rich user experiences related to
its record user interfaces another
google again this side yeah okay so
Google has bought this website recent
one diversity end of next year um this
is a mobile phone social networking
application and was recruited actually
was developed by and I'm like Paul Adam
opera and he was the one who came up
with the housing max electron who
actually he was really last year and
they love attention because he was
working on two old maps and he made that
soup recipes and then together and then
really hotshot now that's what I was
hired by people to develop this song
because there's no social networking so
I you again this is an example of the
web two point oh the question is good it
make my anything who knows I don't know
that yes and that's I think there is
love you custom solution sir oh so this
is example cool for the big companies
dies flickr about my yahoo um anybody
has traveled all the time so here you
can share your pictures flagger you can
share it people who use this now this is
a another website where you can share
your favorite
but also provide our people to it quick
PDF want me to everybody's familiar with
it so much explaining feed but as you
can see it's also translated in lots of
different sites or a different country
so you have a treatment in that Dutch
you're gonna see them here so you have
it in many different country and some is
as director of transphase from Prince's
website native batch princes also a lot
of times because we just come up with
their own ideas themselves reddit which
is a source for us to talk about right
you can vote for social standing in what
people don't refer your story right so
again a lot of social networking online
is similar if you want to show before
point these are people work on producing
news and anime and so on so rather than
going to for instance CNN website they
would go to yourself like this and then
discussion about jessalyn and you would
like to interact here and rather than
both your main-spending on website but
selectivity some people like to think
but in my district I mean there's what
vicious another example again increment
giggling escalating subscribe themselves
that's an online marketplace where
people buy and sell shares and stocks
representing what they think will happen
in the future so that's very interesting
so it hasn't exactly packing yet but the
stuff with the highest price represents
what they of the crown think it's going
to happen so inkling does not use real
money traders extends via the ankle or
inkling which is an imaginary currency
again an hour for interaction that
people are interested if you think about
you to your left on our amendment more
it is how everything you sleep other
business on that there's a software well
I'm not gonna give you an answer because
of this reason that our country in the
next line is that increasingly online
software delivery provides more
usability convenience and value for your
company that's what it seems like
heading for the flexibility and ability
and the connectives on other people and
I'll people who use that web software
it's growing really fast we receive your
helmet websites out there and think
about myspace for instance or transfers
the LinkedIn cell BBC's and divisions of
management
together is that not ignoring many of it
whether it's conscious or not we are
doing and using it apart and our David
in or online we are active in inventory
not necessary to go there just to
retrieve information where can I go
there and do it in Survivor using these
applications hosted on the rack or
inside our organizations we all are
different kinds of qualities you love
you niall ferguson's to help me that
useful for last year and people were
using Amazon rather they're sending the
rings of death so in all kinds of web
technologies are are being used within
companies to get me to consumers some of
it is right add people-powered aspects
of what's important software a positive
developers they are features cairo and
soft working to make pieces morally
terrible to drop you wait community so
it would get the sucker online and if a
lot of these new developments are being
our first used by the early adopters in
vincennes committee i think you said it
is happening we need to pay attention to
it but has barely started and just to
give you a few examples of what people
know SI been a point worried for how
people have been describing about how
well people know technologies are being
used and i have lots of examples of
lives of software that you can fill in
so to do this calendars block filters
compact motion within companies you
would see project management software in
and so on and there's a lot of
possibilities are possib software our
many people
differences to engage rebates
differently with your consumers looking
at this or how or where do we believe
how do you scale these communities how
many people are there and do one hundred
percent of consumers well I would say
that the levels and experiment represent
phases of value creation so France if
you look at the yahoo groups one percent
of user population you might start a
group or a threat so ten percent of
these different populations might
actually participate are typically with
in that group and actually be the author
the content whether you started threat
for responding in a threat it's very
very clear stationary temperature the
higher percent of the user population
therefore is not necessarily active for
they do benefit of the activities of the
one and the other traversing the group
because that becomes your assignment
alert kind of the exceedingly made you
know think about women and main activity
of my mind and the words are influenced
by what they have ready made by them
you're not by market price coming to the
exit the media industries and if you
think about reading streets is that a
lot of them try two different ways to
adapt to the digital well Eric Allen
companies like in the world that meets
our apmt and also filled in streets
people I Colonel Sanders cooperation of
all kinds with integrated and toxic
directly I mean what are these countries
trying to do they know they have to do
something but I will be intimate but do
not really sure what to give
that's my understanding um if you want
to look at or try to develop inside and
our interview creation and management of
where these online communities
communities do what attracted you can
study for trying to find ways to use
these communities already behavior upon
people run and see how you can make
innovative smart depression and
strategies so looking at trying to
figure out what is the people in what's
out there and what is correctable down
how do people behave if you try to
understand that and then link that to
what it is that the country would
succeed you can use them as a strategic
business with her guessing about are
talking about action yes actually we
wanted you have to get that knowledge
back employment back into strategy
formation with your company um what's
important in that is I think is that
means communities or social networking
and so on are in emerging site for them
reckon you our opportunities expense
markets two to three in Game your folks
you aren't you excited or your brand
loyal its own I don't buy increases
return on investments I'll look at that
perspective it means thinking about
different universe thinking about what
it means how you can build trust
relationship with different humors as
obviously at what as we're going to
think you have people of what we do we
may have that to a certain extent but it
also shows that to you and you would
like to you there who thinks that we
would like to do what would like to see
them and which means that we have to
rethink what is what needs what our
company we Department us what we want to
with the solid product you look so
service how young do them and what does
it beautifully boundary who are we who
are they say you have hope that dynamic
and
action needs to be redefined it's no
longer very simple attempt to target
group with people of 17 to 21 interested
in serving so yes it works out to be it
has changed the way you should think
about our consumers you should change
our marketing Molly's in our business on
support you if we working of that which
I actually tries to do too much gets to
hopefully we're able to understand and
get and learn actually looking at our
consumers that backwards of strategy
information within the company so we can
innovate attack and learn from that and
hopefully sustained performance you
haven't revenge and yeah have a few
examples rinses out a few of the suicide
this month we're not going to talk about
women are empowered enough again that's
a whole different discussion but let's
say they have found a good way to do
business or life it's an erotic site
with my girls we're on its cosplay more
than hundreds and documents with
customers and clear thinking and that's
really different very successful
community it's only hard on it's
basically everybody food for it yeah
well about two weeks ago they had 1024
suicide girls and assume I can portray
themselves picture it's there the muscle
pictures they're more than 10,000
articles and you can see the guy over
there let's make the vero very famous
rough times in that scene he's actually
married now to Carmen Electra so it's
all illusion of ingredients kind of
community as you can see recent
everybody has been under on also it's a
block of jewels there you can see how
many minutes ago Sami less entry active
threats as through discussions there as
soon as I feel radio which missy is
actual
the owners of this website its sundays
at mid time midnight and 2am so you have
video radio this is a threat Raven
actually a 62 inside feels like the mess
too so you can actually also go and see
them somewhere I was not only a line
through read mine our earth blocks
written receptions this is actually real
reason after you on the side to you and
I'm sure it's suicide pills also have a
profile on myspace every day it's a nun
thrill Debbie attract among people
traffic through that site as well stay
prepared and you know the director of
merchandising every company has so they
have found this nation market up online
and roughing out of you but a little bit
did I only want to hurt yourself well
whose cooperation by spend i don't
really have to be talking about this
together i'm pretty sure everybody knows
about my strength even hear it started
out a lot with musical film communities
it's more now you see what that love
upcoming events and filming to someone
who try to come up for work are people
here at Huffington schools go home see
that's cool actually it's quite funny i
was in new york and uni uni people in a
bar and they gave me their business
cards and then the next morning your
time today to myspace because of every
American in my myspace people work so
it's I don't don't necessarily know what
we did you sexually my throat respect
something to be part of let every like
and also it's a way for me to to connect
or stay in touch with people that I
cannot lock you down
it's my securities and rip apart on them
seven too many times oh this is wendys
it don't succeed it had lots of friends
so are people actually interested in
10-20 Raiders long and tragic big enough
well I don't really have other
priorities but if you look at any
community a lot of gave companies such
as a people involved they swapped
exactly help engines out there a lot of
them also get going there are with their
sources to make an open retreat for
people to fight but a facility three but
if you buy again usually to get the
tools to be able to make modifications
so this is like unreal engine 3 that's
an example monitor how so they if you
have access to internal volume or a
paper and you intentionally create your
own occupation suit again also you do
not necessarily have to pay pretty that
the wrong people just do that online for
free security into that decide to do
going I'm office information are your
men great navigation groups or maps and
so heading Martin is enormous here are a
few examples of terms of action amateur
boss or absolute rather orchestra so how
can our group is Ahmad and it will never
miss it has become some game himself an
example is also person involved they
have rated game it was so popular of a
modification I wish I became Latin papi
so they bought that that company so they
were
interesting that you see that the heroin
platform steam controller popular they
all serve a setting that circumvent
publishers is rooted in july american
samoa network and has also developed
developer community writing directly
interact with gamers and you can almost
say both sides of games or nothing today
anything is equal on that level they
could tell what they would like to see
whether my forget they would actually
offering their own creations of a game
of dollars every month even so they're
not that tell me if you want some people
come with game ideas and soul and
unintentionally or it's so far has been
really getting above polity back to
involve and and i think it happy to I
think it's actually turning into a
graduation gaming industry's you have
into business and I think creating is
going to be exactly to see how we can
interact with computers and they don't
contest they're not really friends to
interact with a game against trees for
example in book industry that are still
terrified what people do that division
with his current thank you much all
right who like that start on the
question so you know yesterday
have revived to visibility in here
exploder this bandage that spam culture
and it also seems like that and
available knowledge one question I had
about that is if you make the initial
offering commercially you saw that I
believe you opened up montage or
expanded upon tyne I think thanks how
how do you have in that exemplary board
to monitor know how do they buy it back
or mechanism where we how would think
that they're expanding hood I was going
to be the chocolate have how do you have
it has like it rectified so you mean
because not every month obviously it's
being dropped into him yeah i think
there's no well i think let's say from a
business perspective is it's all about
money so let's like red orchestra or can
destroy it so more possible than the
games that were originally for game
developers that to them it was like well
apparently we may have opened something
and it could be that our distribution
may not happen mess which was actually
true the Balkan Mountains right how much
onion came up with a revolutionary when
distributing people all of the universe
so that's what their lords and
definitely evolved the way to work tips
to start working on the new looking into
the problem and that's how i came up
with steam distribution model pounds but
they learn that
games because they were fed up with law
because it's a game please get actually
super games and so on besides them I'm
striking him through popular than Emily
brown server so to a Walkman was really
a way to you too well also that's hidden
content that people to their their their
games and scholarship applications but
they thought well lead to be new wave
and interactive them and we offer a lot
of money then we may be able to access
that four-game our community but we have
to do ultimately such a way then it's
settled i'm not going to be proposed but
you can call you know company structure
or harder and so far to have succeeded
in doing that that there have been
living flexible in a way very laid back
up to the people who support group where
accomplished but they have money
attaching a memory loss but I used to
but so did for 40 guys saying they got a
jump on to happen but it was really that
was very popular among gamers serve all
destroyed white choco I wouldn't mind
dr. Bell then you stay cozy community
Motors Corporation for instance by ball
if there's someone to be sure there must
be something to it cerebral exponent
ignored in attacking children for volume
controls based lounge game so let's buy
it and you can go to platform and they
it goes some sort of structures with the
basket Milton so we will be too much of
a combination of struggle
and I must say I don't you see how that
works in here man how this baby
relatively wasn't we were asking to meet
their duplicates it it's one thing to
hire control from the modification
community in a perfect world will be a
more delicate model for rewarding people
putting evaluation well as I say not
they like to dollywood ready and I
really wanted especially yeah like
little game in new experiences like
going through surviving achieving
particular stages and running soon again
that's what seems to have more and
actually been most yeah and that just
has to follow okay yeah is there anybody
working on what we might call a kind of
recognition economy there where people
are effectively getting paid because
there may be something yeah I mean in
terms of money yes well your articles
not hearing them and like second life no
I mentioned talking about that if you
think about recognition as a capital
it's getting distributed not painful
that summer if you were saying that one
of the ways they know that I'm sure
there must be people this is very often
so be like one of the different recipes
interesting with quick transfer since
you guys are the same you know
one of the officers are doing
circumventing the traditional so
something like the corrosion times any
morning show me the kinds of ways it's
lost and broken at-bat up but it sounds
like with some of these sizes that's
also have another marketing second do
you think of how people sweetie we are
looking at oscillations or was that
tradition marketers would look for that
game now suddenly community yourself
organized take you like that this was
popular a graphically if you put that
together with attention american
generation is not enough Nader's without
intention i'm going to look at your ad
wife is e ad agency maybe give me a mic
movie because i'm going to spend very
seconds looking at this thing that
erosion of the middle man seems to help
the world market I'm just curious if two
are you guys aiming and do stuff and
these sites the answer is no we're not
using those sites except as may be a
means to deliver an audience so every
night and the fundamental question that
we're asking ourselves is a 10 59 and we
understand our community so how do we
make very big money off the community go
on grants question aluminum rims amazon
monetizes I recognition
surgery maybe the grave i get call on
loan from my sight thamizhan my walkman
i get a percentage of the sale it's
better deal at my publishing so he begun
they got more clearly motivates me to go
out and recommend their service over any
other online so I can be imagined
haunting system work memory similar ways
where the whole picture on play my mom
better by the game so why shouldn't I
get a percentage of sale of the game for
every every game consultants way my mom
why not build in some sort of connection
I know it's easier to trace the bread
crumbs from mammoth for me to Amazon
book sale but it is through the game
sale photography the gaming community
demonic demon you should be beginning to
form those relationships the company we
will decide the company's investment and
it sound the alarm should be enough that
the company gives away its access to
tools the bond and that's where you go
you should go to the company that offers
usually best deal valued you're jittery
these fans and waters regenerate our
invisible engines and money in this
economy and the criticism of the mine
economy is it sporting its explorative
play you're essentially outsourcing
three your consumer and the greater four
groups or reviews bikes by this also is
free labor so it'd be much better and
long term for handling but some economic
systems that Justin supported the
production of new content well right
with the Sims has sort of allow people
to sell content reduced to the sounds
through your sights and hundred generate
some revenue often I talk to her about
and he said that he was realizing we
believe a band support your name they
were doing a lot of revenue for the sims
and you wanted ways to take at least
their pump up the gumption flying flying
out getting some revenue stream again
fight with an EI it wasn't recognized
the back to rewrite the charge of use
damn yeah just do just something
danceable questioning yourself if you
will you can spend any time in second
lightning you roll the whole parking lot
on the New York on where the group that
is being called the door and the super
of the Super what did very active money
producers independent company produces
the Second Life shows all this people
put on spectacles invisible members of
the 200,000 they also get conference by
the year from name of the company has
one so this is sort
seems like devotion he is building in
behind riding roping strategy or product
ahead i'm sort of has been Alex diwali
men older harvest our source pancakes to
help us update this we're going to start
out with that source material you guys
penetrating trauma and stronger the
adoptive well that's it well i mean i
find it hard to that's right that's out
number hope so but on the other there's
not i don't think there is room to be a
best practice room what the structure
should be because if it's too structured
have people also remember it's a very
it's a very fragile interaction let's go
a lil intervene let's say you can have a
gazillion my spaces but there was only
one you need to go you know i don't know
how long it's going to less than maybe
two months it will be gone a year and
that was done I mean it's hard to you
right now for me to say well yeah I mean
look at come on going to me I think it
might have done pretty well by offering
the virtual space where people hadn't
panned out and meet each other bill at a
park but of course it's not as in fact
when we go to my second and sold it and
what is more of a dreadful issue and
what I want is waiting on the plane game
so if the derivative terms I think what
you want to achieve
bill so there's Costa moment you have to
buy or you've been before virtual space
if you're not just thinking so on so it
yeah it's pretty hard but I would think
that that's the way we should go that
you have to have really basement
grillage to enter service that
intervention on the downtown so let me
tell you how the second wife makes money
right 995 a month that's one revolution
with Dayton Bible and there's also matt
gaetz my Island for 1250 dollars plus
one fifty dollar month land mass and if
you ther foreign currency exchange to
exchange US dollars you win the Belgian
back they're essentially paying they
make a little bit of transaction costs
on man that's of any money Sonia that
awesome game developers conference
October and said from the podium that
the next words i believe it's EverQuest
you're just currently I think that once
it went any but a month or two be
sitting on that it's going to be free
and they're going to make money by
setting up an ebay marketplaces people
combine itself in the game and that's
how they're going to make their money
they believe that they'll be able take
more money from all transactions because
it's such a GED of the world is more
makes more money than the revenue coming
from subscriptions how do you guys see I
want it because whatever talking books
the business community about this they
serve as it approaches self-employed
remains to be seen how some of these
faces are different papers States or
whatever and people tend to think in
terms of actual dollars for one
in Miami but I think oh we look out of
unity which is a start but if you have
that that's goaltending classicism lunch
all right or if you think about it
search history that constantly we don't
they take me modernizing to think of
those things that are done by others
sort of the patient look at that is
actually so I think the right kind of
certainly distribute models and glam
taxes all monetary screams and have to
monetize it's like monitor someone is
working home well they just know if we
don't think about this and the dollar
now we put in fact in fact I think one
way to home in some folks this is lost
Wi-Fi monopoly I don't think it I think
that's an extremely valuable point which
is what we're saying that this is about
branding and it's about active research
and that's kind that's a strong answer
to gable people start talking about ROI
because you're not measuring roi on the
schedule you're looking at the best sort
of long-term investments in command
building and sources of data for
marketing research those can be turned
into our online but it's a completely
different model than the gravity model
that you've been discussing just my
devotion to turn business model start to
talk about this as a revenue source
right it's eclipta models and everything
else in advertising doesn't notice that
let's come into play what you're doing
is shipping it around you know when my
students probably got this investing
events or when we do cases like Toys R
Us and your flagship brand store on
their times which will never pay out the
many dollars in any way but they've seen
it as just destroying brand building
exercise I get a little nervous about it
because you know in the hard world of
numbers when it when you come up to an
executive you hear somebody with some
real budget making power and is they're
talking about brand building it starts
to sound very fuzzy and fluffy
it's I think your point is is extremely
well taken the question is how do you
think that for the next level of putting
an economic valuation right and that's
what things like attention trust or the
interesting because how many you start
to monetize with me you could
potentially monetize consumer and
detention which is about all of a
certain business is trying to put in a
classroom pull that in the easy to be
you've got that become a hundred-percent
hundred-percent philosophy isn't
building these things themselves just
think about what constantly to know
erection it's your been attention if I
move to another end the engines revving
iteration right to go back so it's not
just the attention by itself but what is
the attention to equipment being able to
trace that in other words the qualities
of attention are the qualities of
attention different when I actually
intentionally say okay here I am pay me
for my time I'm going to watch your ad
and I'm just kind of zoning out watching
an episode of lost and the commercials
come and go and I kind of see them is
that a different kind of attention is
one we don't know yet I mean we've been
studying whether television advertising
actually works or not for about 50 years
and we still don't have an answer so two
trillion deficit up real good plane
lands so this has very quick been very
sophisticated experimental models with
their split cable the same city and
blocks if you've got this commercial at
least once dated and then they measure
the sales effects and local markets and
we still don't know there's nothing of
statistical significance ever really
turned out like your number sir
prosecutors gorgeous yeah the numbers
are there are online just look at the
steady decline after we call for on
casters let's say the metrics that are
out there true or not true our large
present as the noise of the world
increase
space that people actually tattoo that's
all and when there's another you know
that another one reporter but there's
another model but says when you pay that
kind of attention to something we're
going to add you activate what's called
a schemer schema which is like you know
yeah right triangle is neither
constantly counter arguing it is the way
your deposits in stellar so there's a
whole bunch of different parts of
attention returned thank you very much